i'm laura ingram this is the ingram
angle from what feels like a banana
republic tonight
the deep state's revenge that is the
focus of tonight's angle
can i just
stop and just take a breath real quick a
former president's home
has been searched now by a number of fbi
agents
when you look at this in the view of
sort of thirty thousand feet and history
maggie i'll start with you
how big of a moment is this is this a
moment we are all going
to remember yes we're all going to
remember being together on this night
because this is a night where you are
going to remember where you were
yes wiley coyote thinks he finally
caught the roadrunner
[Music]
well the search warrant served on
mar-a-lago this morning had donald
trump's name on it but the real target
of this investigation isn't trump
the real target of this investigation is
you
or anyone who dares to call out and take
on the rank corruption of the d.c
establishment
this is the deep state's revenge
they're trying to show all of us that
will be destroyed if we fight them if we
question the repeated failures of the
pentagon leadership if we make serious
i'm talking about serious moves to
disrupt the status quo here in
washington you know the status quo that
protects the powerful as long as they
play the game
now for decades they got away with
selling us out by letting in 20 million
illegals flooding across our border they
sold us out by sending our manufacturing
jobs to china they sold us out by
wasting trillions on stupid wars in the
middle east
and now they're selling us out by
wasting billions billions more in
ukraine
a year after 13 of our service members
were murdered in afghanistan due to our
own general's incompetence
and think about this tonight still no
one has been fired
you think trump would have ever put away
with any put up with any of this
and if he got back into power they know
he would hold all the right people
accountable for what they've done
if the doj had a real serious case
against trump that was threatening the
republic
they would have charged him months ago
but the word had obviously gone out from
the white house that he needed to be
punished and he needed to be tormented
in any way possible before the midterms
and of course you can always count on
the press right to never question the
powers that be
when the powers that be are democrat
the
biden white house outside the actual
white house not in the justice
department they didn't know they were
blindsided given how buttoned up and
cautious merrick garland is especially
with something as sticky as this it's
hard to imagine that they gave the white
house a heads up i do agree i would be
stunned if anybody in the white house
including the president knew
that's the critical thinking that they
do
but the best tonight i think is andrew
mccabe the disgraced former deputy
director of the fbi he was chiming in
and at the standard now this is wild
it's apparently that if a search warrant
is issued the subject must be guilty
the fbi would not have taken a step as
drastic and serious as this unless they
had good information to indicate that
this was the result of some knowing
willful
intentional acts of removing classified
documents or sensitive documents
documents in violation of some federal
laws
from the man who was a proven liar about
his having talked to the wall street
journal who had an obvious vendetta
against trump going back to 2015. yeah
he's credible
they're obsessed they're obsessed with
knocking trump out of the political
arena and it's look it's obviously hurt
him personally and politically
but this also hurts our trust in our
system of government
because we all see the justice
department's leadership now for what it
is
this is not the image of the lady
justice operating with a blindfold
but this is a praetorian guard that
shields all of those who hold the real
power in this town
surveillance subpoenas search warrants
they're the weapons of choice
which is what they deploy against you
when they're threatened by you
they harass your friends they make you
spend money and look most people they're
not going to tolerate this they're going
to go through it
which is why the deep state usually has
its way
but trump is not most people
and trump isn't the only target liz
cheney has already said that ron
desantis is too close to trump she can't
support him
i think we can all assume that we're
going to get similar treatment if
desantis gets anywhere near the white
house
so they want to scare all of us
into being silent
they don't believe that the gop is
legitimate unless it's controlled by the
establishment types
and they're going to oppose anyone who
tries to make real policy changes and
they're going to use every weapon they
have
but we know all this now we don't
believe in the deep state anymore we
don't trust their titles we're not
impressed by their badges
the principled civil servants inside our
government the ones who still like to
call balls and strikes they're smothered
by all those who choose corruption and
cronyism over professionalism
so i saw them all tonight on the other
nets they were celebrating
tonight but merrick garland may have
just done more to rally the conservative
base
than inflation and high gas prices ever
could
imagine what these people would have
said if the trump doj had executed a
search warrant on hillary clinton's home
or his her home office
anyone remember the clinton foundation
state department scandals no search
warrants there
hunter biden he's being investigated by
the u.s attorney's office in delaware
no search warrant there
no merrick garland authorized raid
eric holder he was held in contempt of
congress
no accountability there
these people though i think they all
know their time is almost up
so they're strafing the landscape and
one last pathetic burst
we don't know where the so-called
investigation is going to end up but
given the recent anti-trump history of
this doj and fbi
there is no reason that trump supporters
should trust motivations or the outcome
here
conservatives are coming back to power
probably in 2024
and when we come back
they will be sorry that they abused the
power of our intel agencies our federal
law enforcement and even our military
and p.s
watch what happens to liz cheney next
week in wyoming and then you'll know
what's coming for the establishment
that's so gleeful about this morning's
search warrant
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else